[Musique]
on va on va monter sur des pas de retour
aux alentours de 14h c'est qu'il ya un
problème devrait plus tarder je crois
que je vois un éclairage sur notre
colline en face
[Musique]
krainer aux jeunes avaient ils sont
beaucoup cinquantaine sont des kalach ah
ouais
beaucoup de jeunes il ya des adolescents
avec des kalachnikov 3 les deux
dernièrement ils sont jana
ça fait plus de 25 ans que des groupes
armés congolais ou étrangers terrorise
l'est de la république démocratique du
congo pour brut x j'ai voulu rencontrer
un chef de guerre pour essayer de
comprendre le déchaînement de violence
là bas comment tu t'appelles mitsubishi
shekels bichkek et tu as quel âge
mitsubishi des dessins 13 ans des jeunes
pour porter une arme oui mais bon vous
êtes beaucoup des jeunes dans le groupe
comme ça je vois ça
[Musique]
comment tu t'appelles richard rutatina
hockey et à quel âge béchard pas
seulement 19 ans oui ça fait longtemps
que tu es dans le groupe armé vois ça tu
as déjà tué des gens oui ok on arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien en place qui sont en train de faire
c'est une démonstration de force parce
qu'il ya la diam arrêt parce que je suis
présent tu veux juste montrer qu'ils
sont bien armés et bien entraînés
officiers sous-officiers catégories
dames en boxe thaï au général ces
reliques utilisation d'enfants soldats
c'est considéré comme un crime de guerre
il ya beaucoup de chefs de groupes armés
qui sont aujourd'hui au tribunal pénal
international pour cette raison à eddy
van aeby la libye les à bongo t&d à coco
sangatte est là et bien là et bissau qui
va la moquette à la punta cana remettait
banaras chowk à quatre macaques en live
arcade et pourtant mais pourtant parmi
vos troupes vous avez des adolescents y
aux hormones antalya moto l'hogneau aux
a's à me pousser
you son modèle le coup lie aux modèles
bachinois base à la cavale dans la
campagne aux halles bâtiment sera
moquait pas à mon forum ouvert mon côté
nabil oignons sont beaux arts au mondial
aux amandes elle n'a chinoise au monde
elle même au monde l amour mon amour mon
pouce est attaché noah n'a besoin d'un
gala
le général en face de moi c'est
constantin bashung a le chef d'un groupe
armé nationaliste dans la région du sud
kivu
c'est un ancien soldat de l'armée
congolaise il a quitté pour diriger sa
propre milice vous allez le voir
ça n'a pas été facile de parler avec vos
collègues ce congo ils ont des freins
traités par le décès ou non qu a connues
poussaris avis au ter me sautait naseaux
style savvy sauter socomie et commune va
laisser la vie sauve à lambeau pas écho
à la solde est ce que vous avez vraiment
l'impression que votre lutte elle est
efficace
les aucun des biens tant violaine a noté
dana lever tôt pour cela qu'à violence
était là j'étais là au niveau cantonal
et kaka n'ont pas une vision sans viola
j'étais hollandais général combien
d'hommes vous avez tué thomas d'haussy
attendait ça s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît juste on reste concentré on n'a
pas beaucoup de temps on reste
concentrés au nova cella est ce que
valent à battambang auteurs babou
diakham wawrinka n'a qu'à ceux qui
montent encore vu aux côtés un coffee
par un bandana km au tempérament qui m'a
confié martin
le général bashung à apprécie
moyennement mes questions sur les
enfants soldats ou sur le nombre de ses
victimes
du coup pour ne pas avoir de problème
j'essaie de changer de sujet général il
paraît que vous avez rêvé de cette
rencontre entre vous et moi
solomon binning d'un gabon matin king
humana monachino si les lois et mon ami
n'a battu nyon ce général est ce que
vous pensez avoir des pouvoirs
surnaturels
nous allons encore puzzles en bois qu'à
la phase i du tout moi je vais me battre
manning à lire
aux homophobes à tous
[Musique]